on November 6 there's an election you
might be thinking oh a new president
already no this is not a presidential
election it's the midterm senator hungry
speak nothing local officials all
Americans are asking themselves the same
questions should I vote how will I know
that I should vote if celebrities don't
tell me to I'm a stone think I should
vote what about John Krasinski have you
guys seen a quiet place yes but that
isn't what this is about right now it's
about celebrities telling regular
Americans that they have to vote many
normal Americans like us don't know what
we should do until celebrities tell us
what to do should I moisturize Jennifer
Aniston says you should that's yes but
should we vote some people are calling
this the most important election of our
lives
but they aren't famous just Tucker Lady
Gaga and Urkel Marlo Smith should I vote
Tom Holland Tom Hardy Thomas the Tank
Engine should I vote Barbara Streisand
Barbara Walters all the Barbara's Ethel
Merman the Harlem Globetrotters Angela
Bassett Kylie Jenner's baby Bruno Mars
cast of Riverdale your silence is
deafening
[Music]